Yep. Here's the article.
Okay, you ready?
I'm quoting Jesus in the tool. Jesus in
the tommo. Let me enlarge it. Peter
Schaefer. Here are his credentials.
Peter Schaefer joined the faculty in
1998, appointed as the Ronald O. Prman
professor of Judeaic Studies and
Professor of Religion. This man is a
scholar. He's a professor. He didn't
write a book trying to demonize the
Jews. He was writing a scholarly tome on
what the toonement says about Jesus.
Okay.
His teaching and research interests have
focused on Jewish history and late
antiquity, the religion, literature,
rabbitic Judaism, Jewish mysticism. He
retired in June 2013. In September 2014,
was appointed director of the Jewish
Museum, Berlin, Germany. Now, where is
this from?
Princeton website.
Princeton University.
Okay, you guys ready to get disgusted?
This comes from Gatine 56B57A
which is available on Safaria, an
Orthodox Jewish website and translated.
So let's look at it from the website
itself. And then he explains its
significance.
And I'm going to contrast that with
Islam. You know that. I'm going to
contrast that with Islam.
As much as you hate Islam and Muhammad,
you can't hate him enough.
At least the Quran honors Isa and
Mediam. Let's go here. You ready?
It's all there in the articles.
Be patient, man. Stop rushing me. I got
to get to Anelos. Don't rush me. I made
the mistake. Here you go. Right here.
Ready? And Peter Schaefer will expound
on it.
You ready? Is it large enough? Can you
see the screen?
>> [snorts]
>> Okay, let's read the Gamarra relates or
Jamara Anelos
Konikos, the son of Titus's sister. Now,
who's Titus? He's the general who burned
Jerusalem and the temple and then
became, I believe, the emperor after his
father's passing. So, Ankeelos is the
nephew of Titus, wanted to convert to
Judaism. So he raised Titus from the
dead.
Necromancy. He contacted a spirit. He
died. He went and raised Titus from the
grave through necromancy and said to
him, "Who is most important in the
world?" In that world where you are now
in the underworld, who's the most
important? Titus said to him, "The
Jewish people [clears throat]
asked him, should I then attach myself
to them here in the world, in this
world?" Titus said to him, "Their
commandments are numerous. you will not
be able to fulfill them. It is best that
you do as follows. Go out and battle
against them that world and you'll
become the chief. As it is written, her
adversaries have become the chief.
Lamentations 15. Which means anyone who
distresses, Israel will become the
chief. Anelos or Analos said to him,
"What is the punishment of that man?"
Meaning, if you attack Israel like you
did, Titus, what's your punishment?
euphemism for Titus himself. In next
row, Titus said to now watch, the tom is
talking about the kind of punishments
God will inflict depending on the sin.
And it uses three examples of people
being punished for their sin against
Israel. Titus, Balum, Balam, and Jesus.
So he raises Jesus's spirit.
Watch the blasphemy. So Titus, what
happens to those people who did what you
did? That which he decreed against
himself as he underos the following.
Every day his ashes are gathered and
they judge him and they burn him and
they scatter him over the seven seas. So
what is the punishment? Like Titus
burned Jerusalem, he's being burned over
and over again. Burn, ashes spread.
Restored, burned, ashes spread. And this
is going to happen to him forever.
His punishment is he'll be eternally
being burnt to ashes, have his ashes
spread, restored, burned over and over
again.
In other words, he will not be led out
of hell. Because I guess I you may not
know this. In the rabbitic tradition,
evildoers who haven't committed these
heinous crimes will burn in hell for 12
years, 12 months, but then they'll come
out and be wiped out of existence. Are
you listening?
The punishment of evildoers is that they
go to hell for 12 months, then they're
taken out and wiped out of existence.
They will not be allowed a share in the
life to come. Not with Titus and Jesus.
According to the Talmud, Titus and Jesus
will be punished forever. They will not
be taken out of hell a year later and
wiped out of existence. They will
continue to suffer, which means
atonement teaches Jesus will continue to
burn and forever.
That's atonement.
Jesus will burn in forever and ever
according to the rabbis.
You guys hear what I just said?
And so Peter Schaefer explains why is
Jesus being punished with burning.
Let's see.
Okay.
An Kelos on Kelos then went and raised
Balam. Balam
from the grave through necromancy. He
said to him, "Who is most important in
that world? Where are you now?" Balam.
Balam said to him, "The Jewish people."
See again all three of them saying that
the Jews are the most important people
in the world to come. [clears throat]
Anos
said to him, asked him, "Should I then
attach myself to them here in this
world?" Bam. Balam said to him, "You
shall not seek their peace or their will
for all the days."
Ya, [clears throat]
speak to my throat, Lord. Rebuke S. Anel
said to him, "What is the punishment of
that man?" A euphemism for Baum himself
and the next world. Now, this is why,
guys, in previous sessions, I had
confused and thank the Lord you were
there to correct me. I thought it said
Jesus was burning and boiling semen. No,
it's Balum who was. The reason why I got
confused because according to certain
authorities
and certain copies of the tomud where
the name Jesus appeared, they changed it
to Balum Balam. Now, I'll explain why in
a minute. [clears throat]
There was an edict sent out to the Jews
to expune remove all references to Jesus
because the Catholic Church found out
about these nasty blasphemous statements
to Jesus and they were being called
forth to give an answer. Why are you
blaspheing Jesus in your books? So an
edict was made. Get all the copies you
can remove his name. So in some copies
the name Jesus was changed to Balam.
Now, how do we know that? Because there
are manuscripts that survive with the
name Jesus in those places. That's how
we know.
You got it. That's in the book. Just be
patient, brother. That's in the book.
No, it's actually syncing with the book.
You with me there?
Now watch here. Ankillos said to him,
"What is the punish of that man?" You
from Balam himself. In the next word,
Balam said to him, "He is cooking and
boiling semen." What a disgusting book,
dude. As he caused Israel to engage in
lentious behavior with the daughters of
Now Peter Schaeer is going to explain
why each one of them were punished the
way they did. Now, why was Titus
punished with burning? Because he burned
Jerusalem. Why is Balam being punished
with boiling semen? Because what did he
do? He enticed Israel to commit sexual
orgies. And what's the result of a
sexual orgy? Semen. So now he's going to
burn in that seaman
that he enticed Israel to emit by
committing sexual origins in their
worship of Bal. Do you understand?
The punishment
meets the crime they committed.
Now let's go to Jesus. You ready? Here
it is. This is safaria.com. They don't
pull any punches. They say Jesus of
Nazarene. Safaria.com.
Did you get that, Michael Loftton?
When over two years ago, I went after
you because you're trying to deny that
Jesus is mentioned in the atonement. You
remember that, Mike? Michael Loftton.
And I had to call you out for it. Here
in your face, Michael Loftton.
Safaria.org
translate. And in their manuscripts it's
Jesus the Nazarene.
Okay. Unilos then went and raised Jesus
the Nazarene from the grave through
necro necromancy. Ankulus said to him
who is most important in that world
[clears throat]
where you are now. Jesus said to him the
Jewish people. Ain't it writing? That's
what the Christian Zionist say.
The Christian Zionists say what the
Jesus of the atonement says. Was
that ironic?
Right.
So then why why is he suffering?
Anko said asked him should I then attach
myself to them in this world? Jesus said
to him their welfare you shall seek
their misfortune you shall not seek. For
anyone who touches them them is
regardless if he were touching the apple
of his eye. Man, that sounds like what
Christian Zionists say.
So the Jesus of the Tmud is in hell
burning and boiling
and he's warning then people, hey, cling
to Israel. Follow Israel because they're
God's people and don't seek their harm.
That's exactly the script of Christian
Zionism.
Right? Tell that to Lloyd Dion who tries
to defend the atonement. Now watch said
to him, "What is the punishment of that
man?" A euphemism for Jesus himself and
next world. So now watch it. Watch
Jesus's punishment.
Jesus said to him, he is punished with
boiling excrement. Jesus is being
burned, boiling, and
And
so Dan Bellazarian was right. Now he too
became an extremist. See this is the
danger. You hate Islam and Judaism with
a passion. They're both from the pit of
hell. But at least the Quran doesn't say
these things about Jesus.
The Orthodox Jews do.
You want me there?
Okay. So now watch here. And this was
his sin. Why is Jesus boiling in?
Because he mocked the words of the
sages. Cuz he went against the
Pharisees.
Come and see the difference between the
sinners of Israel and the prophets of
the nations of the world. So notice
Jesus is a sinner of Israel.
And yet as a sinner of Israel, he still
has to be honest enough saying be good
to the Jews. As Balam who was a prophet
wished Israel harm, whereas Jesus
Nazarene who was a Jewish sinner sought
their wellbeing.
So Jesus is the sinner of Israel.
Jesus is the sinner of Israel.
Now where did I get this from?
Safar.org. Are they lying too that
they're inserting the word Jesus?
No. Because that's what they did. They
said about Jesus. Now watch here.
Did I Why did I Oh, yeah. I'm sorry.
That was it because I'm on the page.
Here it is. And it's in my article.
There you go.
So now Peter Schaefer is explaining
why is it Jesus is being punished and he
explains he comes up with a theory
because notice the punishment of Balum
met you know matched his sin. Why is he
boiling in semen? Because what did he
do? He enticed Israel to commit sexual
orgies and a blatant act of idolatry.
See the semen? The sin of sexual
immorality. Titus is being burned over
and over again. Why is he being burned
over and over again?
Yeah, I'm going to do a session on the
Holy Mother. That's going to be part
two. Wait till I show you what they say
about the Holy Mother.
You're antitheatic, FAM. YOU'RE GOING TO
BE TARGETED NOW. We're going to shut you
down. You ain't going to get seven G's.
Yeah. Stick it where the sun don't
shine. Pray I can be a man of holiness
and boldness and face death for Jesus
and not back down because without Christ
I'm a coward. He's [clears throat] my
strength. So now guys, you understand,
right? Titus is being burned because he
burned Jerusalem.
Balam is is boiling in semen because he
enticed Israel sexual morality. That
means Christ must have done something to
merit him burning in Well, guess
what?
Peter Schaefer thinks it's because of
two sayings of Jesus.
That means the rabbis were aware of the
teachings of Jesus.
So he thinks the reason why the rabbis
say Jesus is burning burning a
because of his saying in Mark 7:18 to
23. It's not what you put inside of you
that defiles you. It's what comes out of
your mouth, your heart. Because what
goes inside you comes out. Oh, so you
think food doesn't defile you? because
it goes in and comes out of. So then
you're going to burn in that very that
comes out of you. See the blasphemy.
You see the blasphemy
Schaefer thinks because the Lord said
it doesn't matter what you eat. Mark
7:18 to23 and he cites it because it'll
go inside and comes out.
It's what comes out of your heart that
defiles you because from your heart
comes immoralities,
adulteries, murder, lying. So they say,
"Oh, so you're saying it doesn't matter
what you eat. What you eat doesn't
matter because it'll come out of well
then you're going to boil and that comes
out of you."
The second thing they do is they mock
the Holy Eucharist. Peter Schaefer is
convinced this is also an attack on the
Eucharist. Meaning when Jesus said, "Eat
my flesh and drink my blood, you'll have
life." Peter Schaefer thinks that what
the rabbi is saying, "No, no, no, no. If
you eat his flesh and drink his blood,
it will come out as as well." Because
remember what Jesus said, anything you
eat will come out of. So eating bread
and wine that you think is blood is is
his is his body and blood, all that's
going to benefit you is that you're
going to sh blasphemy.
blasphemy.
It's an attack on the Eucharist and on
Jesus's teaching.